[Music]
good evening thank you for joining us
for tonight's special honoring black
history i'm kirsten joyce
and i'm christian casadas tonight we're
going to spend the next half hour
highlighting
black community members who are making a
difference in our city
we'll also be joined by bianca holman
with more coverage
from the historic west side district and
we'll be profiling
a new program encouraging local students
to read we'll also meet a teacher
who's making sure all of his students
feel seen
and heard we start tonight with the
healthcare heroes who have played a
major role in the covid19 pandemic
delicia sullivan is a medical assistant
for the unlv school of medicine
her role to provide much care to
patients as needed
of course that includes filling
prescriptions making sure everything is
clean
and vaccinating people sullivan says
being a medical assistant
was something she wanted to become when
her mother was diagnosed with lupus
her biggest goal is to make sure every
patient feels safe and comfortable
take care of each one as if they were
your own
so i'm honored to do this i'm actually
just
really honored to be able to mix the
solution
for the pfizer or to inject a patient
it's just
to me it's an honor i see us getting
back to a norm
it may not be the the norm that we had
before
but it will be a new norm that we can
adjust to you know
and it's going to take some time and to
say the least
everybody has to play their part in
sullivan's message be aware of where you
come from and who paved the way for you
most importantly don't give up on your
dreams
well pastors are helping keep the faith
strong during such unprecedented times
lucius bowen the third is a victory
missionary baptist church pastor he says
the pandemic has been devastating for so
many reasons
and not being able to congregate in
church and worship adds to it
for families who are battling the virus
or can't attend services
he implemented streaming them so people
can still worship
he also tries to keep his community
connected through bible study
weekend worship services sunday's school
class and his prayer
conference call this pandemic is larger
than anything that you've ever gone
through
but god has taken you through things and
what i would encourage you to do is
remember what he's done from
for you in the past we have to
understand is the same god that created
us created scientists and created
doctors and if they
found a vaccine that could help prevent
us
from experiencing the pain and even
death
from covid19 i would encourage you to do
so
bowen's message to the community don't
let the pandemic discourage you he says
quote this too shall pass
you don't see too many black judges in
nevada courtrooms but that is slowly
starting to change
orcomanna introduces us to two local
african-american judges who have made
history
and explains how they are encouraging
the next generation
i think it's very important that the
court represent this community
trailblazer icon judge tierra jones
balances tons of titles thanks to her
historic position of power
i became the first african-american
woman to sit on the state court bench in
the state of nevada
that happened in 2017 jones tells me her
diversity brings a different perspective
to the courtroom
something extremely essential as
african-americans continue to be
disproportionately incarcerated
one of the reasons i wanted to be a
judge is to make a difference it's my
job to follow the law but there's also
always
different life experiences and different
things that
are a part of your culture that are a
part of your background
that you bring to your everyday
decisions there are 58 judges in
nevada's eighth judicial district court
which serves clark county
jones is one of five african americans
currently on that bench
some were just elected in 2020 i
officially
started on january 4. dee butler is the
first african-american judge in clark
county district court's family division
it is nice to be the first but hopefully
not the last
she says growing up she never saw judges
that looked like
her but witnessing tierra jones first as
a public defender then as a judge
inspired her campaign when you're
talking about
mentors just life mentors attorney
mentors and then now
a judge mentor she is a key person
that i look up to jones also does a lot
of work with the valley's youth and says
she sees it as a responsibility
i think it's super important that i pave
the way for those who come after me
but she knows the road to representation
is a marathon
not a sprint and blazing a trail takes
time
i think we are definitely making
progress but there's definitely still
work that needs to be done
orco mana 8 news now
judge jones various mentorship roles
range from speaking to kids at valley
schools
to providing professional advice to
current law students
she says it's all about showing everyone
especially black girls that a career in
law
is possible well still to come on
honoring black history the effort from a
local family to educate the younger
generation
on the rich culture i'm bianca holman
and ahead i'll explain
the significance this part of the valley
has on las vegas
thanks for staying with us for this
eight news now special honoring black
history
i'm 8 news now anchor bianca holman and
i'm here
in las vegas historic west side now this
neighborhood is rich in african-american
history
it's home to the historic berkeley
square the first nevada subdivision
designed for the black community
and it housed the moulin rouge the first
integrated casino
now two new monuments are on display
calling attention to
the neighborhood's prominence the rich
culture that took place on the west side
has never been forgotten
now new signs are up created by artist
harold ford
this is just one way the city hopes to
revitalize the area
there's a sense of pride that we all
have we love telling people that i'm
from the west side
we wear it on our shoulder and this will
just reiterate the fact that
when they say that people will know
where the historic west side is
the sign on the north side of the u.s 95
off ramp is not completely finished yet
but will have a four foot wide walking
path allowing people to come up and take
pictures
also in this neighborhood the historic
west side school
it's a two room schoolhouse built in
1923 with two more rooms added in 1928
it first served as a school for local
paiute children but as the area grew
with big construction projects
such as what would become nellis air
force base and hoover dam
it became a school to almost exclusively
african american students
during segregation the historic west
side was the only place where african
americans could live
attend school or own a business in the
valley
speaking of history black soldiers have
played a major role in our united states
armed forces since the 1700s in the
revolutionary war all the way to present
day
now while black service members are
visible they're still climbing the ranks
into lead roles
[Music]
during the pandemic our united states
air force thunderbirds flew across our
skies to honor
front line workers energy is always high
folks are excited kids are screaming and
yelling and jumping up and down with
excitement
as america's ambassadors in blue they've
got a secret weapon that keeps them
running smoothly
captain rimo shay nelson this is
something that i've always wanted to be
a part of
i was just kind of like blown away and
speechless but also like very excited
for the opportunity
to be a part of this team nelson a
howard university graduate
has lived across the world korea germany
turkey and now nellis air force base
coming from modest beginnings it was her
stepfather's stories of his time in the
navy
that left an impression i am so thankful
because he really taught me the
importance of serving others
nelson is the thunderbird's first black
female officer
when i found out i was extremely humbled
she's the team's public affairs officer
her role is selective nelson is the 12th
person to have the position since the
team started in 1953.
she leads an incredible team and as a
leader of that team they're the first
people to interface with the public
black soldiers have played a major role
in armed forces
from the buffalo soldiers tuskegee
airmen to the air force chief of staff
general charles brown for young black
girls to be able to see themselves
in me for them to get an opportunity to
see what's possible
is an absolute honor when we can inspire
folks to do that because they can relate
to us
that's very effective we can only do
that when we display diversity
and her vision for the future i hope
that we continue to grow
as a force and to be a reflection of the
people that we actually serve
now earlier we mentioned the moulin
rouge and berkeley square
and you may be surprised to find out
that the most tangible pieces of that
history
are in the neon boneyard museum berkeley
square was designed by pioneering
architect paul williams
williams also designed the laconcho
motel and the sign
now sits in the bone yard you'll also
find the sign for the moulin rouge
along with some of the original neon
that still works
stay with us we've got more ahead
including a chance to meet one of ccsd's
most
valuable teachers the goal for me as an
instructor is always to
empower students and ensure that they
have the they don't see any
limits to the creativity it can bring to
to their lives we'll meet mr lang and
learn what it is he does that helps his
students realize their full potential
and the family of a former educator
realizes there's still a lot of work to
be done when it comes to reading level
equality
and they're working hard to close the
gap stay with us
[Music]
one clark county school district teacher
is making sure students
self-reflect he wants them to realize
their point of view
opinions and story matter that's right
well eight news now reporter sally
jaramillo spoke to him
and tell us more she tells us more about
his initiative in empowering students
lives
being someone who was pretty tech
forward before this
i think definitely lessened the um
i guess the complication of having to do
distance learning
michael lang has been a ccsd technology
instructor for 17 years
he is guiding his students at laura
deering elementary to change the world
the goal for me as an instructor is
always to empower students and ensure
that they have the
um they don't see any limits to the the
creativity it can bring to
uh to their lives one of the the reasons
why i was always drawn to apple products
is the the the ease in which one can
integrate those products into your
classroom and allow students to really
dream big
in 2020 lang along with fifth grade
students looked at the world and focused
on what was valuable to them
in a two and a half minute video
students voiced their opinions
then apple picked it up having people
look at my students as as role models as
people that could do things and i think
that was very empowering not only to
those fifth grade students but also
as an instructor to say okay cool uh i
perhaps am on the right path to get
these students doing what we need them
to do
lang says this fueled him to think
bigger this school year
and reached out to all grades i hate
the idea that we can only talk about uh
you know
the martin luther king's and the cesar
chavez is in the doors
and stuff during those months there's a
um
an importance that that life should
she give you and that's an important you
should live
with that power every day the first part
of lang's project is designed to show
students they are valuable by using the
children's book you matter
by christian robinson students will also
use
ipad to capture and edit images of
themselves
family neighbors and craft why they
matter using the pbs kids scratch
junior coding app on ipad we kind of
came out of
um the idea that a lot
of what we do in school is look at this
other person
as this role model as this superhero as
whatever
and again this not this um really
imbuing this sense of self-confidence
this is
self-esteem lang wants the students to
know they are important and deserve an
opportunity to show
who they are through self-portraits they
will also look at some very important
people who have paved the way
where we are now wasn't where we always
were finally
in the ima dreamer 2 segment lang will
ask them how they can be of service to
each other
he wants the students to understand the
story of las vegas
the story of nevada is bigger than the
things we see on a regular basis
we're not a perfect community but we're
a community that is
going through the process of being
perfected sally jerramillo reporting in
las vegas
well students will complete interactive
workbooks and keynote for each part of
the project
they will then compile their thoughts
into a collaborative book of their ideas
in which
they will have the opportunity to share
with the community organizers
and legislators how fantastic wow
well as we know small business owners
have been hit hard by the pandemic
felicia parkers is a black business
owner she is the co-founder of occasion
baskets while striving to keep her
business going she is also giving back
to the community
parker says her biggest inspiration is
former first lady michelle obama
she says her goal is to bring joy to
others through her personalized baskets
moved by frontline workers she's shown
her gratitude by giving out more than
100 baskets to seven hospital ers
and her giving doesn't stop there we
give back
every year we have a give back
initiative a give back program that we
work on every year and so what we try to
do is
give to organizations again that touch
our hearts personally
i'm a mother i'm a wife and i'm a
minority
so a lot of those hit very close to home
for me
some of those organizations include the
school district project 150
hope for prisoners and the women's
resource center
well a las vegas family has launched an
effort to get young children
into reading it's all themed for black
history month and read by
local people of color about civil rights
love
and diversity long before you took your
place in this world
you were dreamed of it's a line from the
book all because you matter that
barbershop owner jarrod essler is
reading to children online
i have two little kids myself you know a
six-year-old and a four-year-old
and i believe it's really important just
to read to them every night
this is one of 25 special books written
by someone of color
and tells a story about a black or brown
person and you hear pop-ups
whispers it's part of a virtual reading
series for black history month called
we see you which was launched by the
parker family and their organization
sarubana culture it included themes like
civil rights
love and activism this project is
extremely intentional
in the way that we wanted our
the kids that were viewing these videos
to also
turn on the youtube video and to see
people who look like them
reading who have had an array of careers
we had a vision of a book sharing
initiative trisha parker a former
teacher and her husband got the idea
after spotting an
outdoor library in la and wanted to get
more children
interested in reading 82 of african
american children were
reading below proficient level 77
of latinx students were reading below
proficient level
one day you'll be big enough to reach it
yourself the couple decided to do a
daily book read online by authors of
color and read by las vegas residents
also of color that children could look
up to among the group
teachers business owners and other black
professionals like cj hayes
it's perfectly fine to ask for help so
to see
people of color in books and show that
to my daughter at a young age
it's going to really give her that
confidence as she grows and that's why i
think this is important
the books are targeting young children
and each clip is free the production
according to the parkers is built on
love and hope to get more kids of color
interested in the rich culture
well new book reads are posted during
the week you can go online and have one
of 25 books read free of charge
visit 8newsnow.com for the link
ahead on honoring black history who
doesn't love a home-cooked meal
we talked to grits cafe about how owners
felt the need to keep the soul alive
during the pandemic
[Music]
we all know food is comfort and during
these times we all need a little bit of
it
local business grits cafe says it will
continue to feed the community's soul
through these times sally had a meal
with the story
grace cafe is a community
based restaurant we've been in business
now for 14 years
grits cafe says it's the ritz for the
grids
located near martha luther king and lake
mead boulevard
it offers southern familiarity to diners
we're all about economic empowerment so
when i first originally opened grits
cafe
my idea was to have a cafe where
people would come and do business and
they would feel like they were at home
in their mother's kitchen
trina giles owns grits cafe while trying
to stay afloat
and adapt to changes during the pandemic
she also continues to give back to the
community
including first responders i believe
that it's important to make sure that we
provide
since we're being blessed with our loyal
customer base that we really do provide
some assistance to youth organizations
that's trying to make an
impact on our youth and bring them up in
a better light
despite closures and capacity reductions
she strives to bring loyal customers
quality cuisine our number one seller
is our chicken and waffles so
southern fried chicken you can accompany
it with grits
and our grits you can top any way you
like from home style potatoes to chicken
fried steak
catfish biscuits and gravy you can find
everything that brings you that southern
comfort food
it can fix a lot of things when it's
the food is good that's why she's
feeding the valley one grits bowl
at a time her overall message to keep
the faith
stay positive there are a lot of
opportunities
out there she encourages everyone to
think outside the box
keep growing and most importantly create
more jobs and opportunities for the
people in our community
i believe that all that i am i owe
to someone else who came before me sally
jaramillo 8 news now
that finishes our hidden history special
right here on channel 8.
for more stories on black history and
the impact from major figures go to
8newsnow.com
thank you for joining us